los gases lacrimógenos cubren la ciudad
de la paz en bolivia cientos de
cocaleros se enfrentaron con la policía
del país la atención aumentó por el
pedido de los manifestantes de cerrar un
mercado de hoja de coca manejado por un
sindicato supuestamente oficialista una
vez que gobierna que soluciones porque
mira vamos a sólo nos perjudica como
vendedores ya no podemos vender nada y
por eso una vez del gobierno que en su
vez ya no es de una vez el conflicto no
es algo nuevo comenzó a principios de
agosto cuando cientos integrantes de la
asociación departamental de productores
de coca adepcoca opositores al gobierno
del izquierdista luis arse salieron a
las calles para exigir el cierre del
mercado
aseguraban que era ilegal y que tenía el
apoyo oficialista y defendían manejar el
único mercado legítimo
la asociación apela a la ley general de
la coca se reconoce en el departamento
de la paz del mercado de la adepcoca y
en el departamento de cochabamba el
mercado de sacaba
el gobierno ha dicho que la norma no es
específica y ha llamado el diálogo en
múltiples ocasiones pero este no ha
tenido efecto en las partes encontradas
el gobierno no puede gobernar pues que
se vaya porque está haciendo mucho daño
no solo los colocadores a nivel nacional
están dañando
en la actualidad 90% del negocio de la
hoja de coca legal en bolivia con un
valor de unos 173 millones de dólares al
año pasa por el mercado de adepcoca
bolivia podría repetir la situación de
2021 entiendo un conflicto similar dejó
38 civiles y 29 policías heridos